[Müzik]
inanamıyorum öyle söyleyeyim
temayı söylediler dijital anormal diye
tabii hemen Muhtemelen diğer bütün
konuşmacılarda olduğu gibi benim de
Suratımda ne demek acaba bu şeyi belirdi
belki sizde de belirtmiştir okuduğunuzda
gördüğünüz de temayı ama şimdi dijitali
anlatacağım ama anormal Ya aslında biraz
kavramlar üzerinden gitmek lazım çünkü
anlaşamıyor olmamızın Yani dünyada
anlaşılamıyor olmasının insanların
toplumların birbiriyle anlaşamıyor
olmasının kavram karma çabaları ile
alakalı olduğunu düşünüyorum örneğin;
anormal kavramı her toplumda bambaşka
bir yere tekabül edebilir Öyle mi yani
herkes için başka bir anlamı olabilir
aslında anormalin ya da başka bir
karşılığı olabilir ya da ahlak
kavramının örneği Bu da mesela çokça
karıştırılan ya da çok çok farklı
karşılık bulan toplumlarca kültürlerce
çokça fazla karşılık bulan bir kavram
ahlak Örneğin şu anda burada ben sahneye
4 kişi alsam alsam ve desem ki ahlak
konusunda konuşacağız tartışacağız şimdi
eğer ahlak tanımlarımız farklı ise bakın
tanımıyorum karşılık demiyorum aslında
kavga etme ihtimalimiz çok yüksek
Halbuki ahlak kelimesinin dünyanın
nereye giderseniz gidin bir tane sözlük
anlamı vardır bir tanedir O birkaç
cümleden oluşabilir ama her dilde her
kültürde aynı anlama gelir ahlak eğer
biz bunu sözlük tanımı olarak biliyorsak
ve bunun üzerine konuşuyorsak kavga
etmeyiz Aslında o zaman farklılıklara
saygı duymaya başlarız Ama öyle olmuyor
anormal de böyle bir kelime işte Bence
doğru ayıralım mı biraz etimolojik Yani
ben burada kimseye etimoloji dersi
vermeye gelmedim ama
önce normalden başlayalım normdan
türüyor olduğunu varsayıyoruz değil mi
norm ne demek aslında Kural Dolayısıyla
normale de biz kurallara uyan kurallar
dahilinde olan diyoruz
kaçımız Gerçekten böyle bir hayat sürmek
istiyoruz acaba bir biraz kafesin içinde
olmak gibi geliyor Çünkü fazla normal
olmak norm mal olmak o yüzden anormalin
bir cazibesi var hepimizin Aslında
peşinde koştuğu bugün bunca insanın
başka herhangi bir şey yapmak yerine
buraya gelip anormal kavramını ya da
dijital anormal kavramını dinlemek üzere
buraya toplanıyor olmasının da Aslında
bundan 2 saat önceki normalinizle kavga
ediyor onunla çatışıyor olmanızla
doğrudan alakası olduğunu düşünüyorum o
yüzden de anormal üzerine Aslında
epeyce düşünmek gerektiğini söylüyorum
şimdi
dijital kavramına da Gelecek olursak
dijital gerçekten anormal Bu arada
özellikle son 3 senede bambaşka bir yere
geldi Son 20 yılda hele daha da başka
bir yere geldi
bir araştırma diyor ki
2000 yılına kadar var olan veri akışıyla
Son 20 yılda var olan veri akışını
kıyasladığınızda Son 20 yıldaki veri
akışı ağır basıyor kat da kat
düşünebiliyor musunuz Nasıl bir dünyaya
geldiğimizi ve şu an biz burada
otururken bizim doğru bildiğimiz bir
sürü şeyin aslında ne kadar değiştiğini
dünyada Yani eli Twitter'a gitmeyen var
mı Mesela iki saattir ya bir bakmak
istemiyor muyuz Hele ki böyle bir
zamanda ne olduğuna şu anda istiyoruz
yani çünkü orada sürekli bir şeyler
değişiyor Sürekli yeni normaller oluyor
dolayısıyla bir önceki ya anormal oluyor
ya da
Aslında Eskiler normal kalıyor geçiyor O
yüzden bu kavramları bir üzerine Aslında
düşünelim burada Bunun cevabını vermek
binlerce yıllık soruya cevabı vermek
için çıkmadı böyle bir yetkinliğin de
olduğunu hissetmiyorum Ama bu soruları
ortaya atmak hoşuma gidiyor açıkçası
Çünkü hepimizin aslında kendi
dinamiklerimize göre bunlara vereceği
cevabı var Bunu biliyorum
İşime gelince ben Virgin radio'da bir
sabah Show olsun diyorum Bir radyocuyum
ve bir de sahne şovum var işte sınav
gecesi adı altında bir sahne şov
yapıyorum burada da aslında bizim işte
mezun olana kadar ya da Hayatın her
alanında Aslında çalışırken de türkaka
ettiğimiz Bu sınavlar sınavlar sürekli
ölçme değerlendirme hali sürekli Bir
analiz altında olma hali falan bunun
bizim sürekli şikayet ettiğimiz bir şey
ama Yeri geliyor 20 kişinin kutu
açmasını yıllarca muhteşem reytinglerle
seyredebiliyoruz Yani aslında o heyecan
o biraz sonra ne olacak işte bir soru
sorulsun cevabı verirsin doğru mu
çıkacak ya da işte küçük mü hissediyor
büyük mü hissediyor falan biz bunları
seviyoruz aslında yani İnsanın sürekli
bir yarış halinde olma bir önce bir soru
yaratıp ondan sonra ona cevaplamaya
çalışma arzusu
Bugün aslında biraz sonra anlatılacak
olan
oyunla öğrenmeye de çok tekabül eden bir
şey
sahne işim var Bunu aynı zamanda bir
dijital karşılığı da var
dijital öyle bir yere geldi ki
bundan 2 sene önce Podcast dediğimizde
belki salonun ne olur hani sözüm
meclisten dışarı ama hani bir şeyi
çoğunluk çoğunluğu anlatabilmek için
söylüyorum belki salonun yarısı ne
anlama geldiğini bile bilmezken ya da
toplumun diyelim şimdilerde Podcast
Dünyası Bugün bizim karasal ya da ana
akım diye adlandırdığımız Medya
içerikleri kadar etkili ve o kadar da
iyi fiyata satılabiliyor bunu hani
bayağı içeriden bir yerden söylüyorum o
fiyatlara da satılabiliyor podcasti
içerikleri Belki de hayatınızda Takip
ettiğiniz en az birkaç Podcast vardır
yoksa da tavsiye ederim açıkçası
muhteşem
muhteşem içerikler var Podcast
dünyasında çok da kolaylıkları ücretsiz
ulaşabileceğiniz bir sürede Podcast var
Dolayısıyla dijital Aslında çok kısa
zamanda bu hale de geldi yani bundan 2
yıl önce ölçülemeyen hatta ölçülebildiği
halde ölçülemeyen demeyeyim çok yanlış
olur Çünkü dijital tam anlamıyla
ölçülebilen de bir şey neden böyle
söylüyorum bugün bir YouTube videosu
yayınladığınızda o YouTube videosunu
kaç sarışın kadının izlediğini bile
bilebilecek kırılımlar var artık
biliyorsunuz Yani bu dijital dünyada bir
içerik yayınladığınızda o içeriği
dinleyecek Yani kimlerin dinlemesini
istediğinizi seçebiliyorsunuz ve size
Google şöyle sorularına bile sorabiliyor
son iki hafta içerisinde yurt dışından
gelmiş olan insanlar
bunlara gönderebiliyorsunuz içeriğiniz
mesela böyle kırılımlar var televizyonda
böyle şeyler yok Allah ne verdiyse
yayınlıyorsunuz
herhalde izleniyordur gibi bir karşılığı
var yani orada Fakat bu daha pahalıydı
bu kadar ölçülebiliyor olmasına rağmen
dijital bunların 2-3 sene önceye kadar
öyle değildi Muhtemelen pandeminin de
etkisiyle dijitalin tüketilmeye dijital
içeriklerin bu kadar yoğun tüketilmeye
başlamasıyla artık Medya değeri olarak
da O noktaya geldi Dolayısıyla bugün
dijital anormal dediğimiz şey artık
hayatımızın normali oldu Hacettepe
Üniversitesi'nin bir seminerine
söyleşisine davet edelim o zamandı Çünkü
Game medyayı takip ediyor musunuz
bilmiyorum game'in kuruluş aşamasında
marka ve içerik Entegrasyonu
yöneticiliği yaptım
markalarla bizdeki içerikleri entegre
etmek ya da markalara kendi braifleri
doğrultusunda yeni içerikler yazmak
üzere bir hem kreatif hem de entegrasyon
açısından yine kreativite gerektiren bir
işti o ve bunun üzerine montajaya davet
ettim ve dediler ki dijital dünyayı işte
mesela
dizi ve sinema içeriklerini Örneğin
nerede görüyorsunuz ya bundan 8 yıl
sonra 10 yıl sonra 20 yıl sonra ben de
onlara dedim ki çok burada hani şey
yapmaya gerek niyet okumaya ya da
Gelecekle alakalı böyle kehanette
bulunmaya gerek yok Bundan tam 20 yıl
önce 25 yıl önce dönün izlediğiniz
diziler bilmiyorum yaşı Hani burada
tutanlar var mı ortalaması kaç
bilmiyorum ama ve Kara Melek falan gibi
diziler var falan Aydan Şener diye bir
kadın vardı sineması hiç yok ama
dizileri ile falan çok ünlü bir kadın
vardı biliyorsunuz Tolga savacılar falan
o dönemin dizileri Alişan Aynalı Tahir
falan Şimdi bunlar baktığınız zaman
bizim böyle içeride gıt gıt güldüğümüz
falan içerikler gibi görünüyor ama bir
bakıyorsunuz abi açın rica ediyorum
sizden YouTube'a Kara melekesin Aynalı
Tahir yazın Mesela herhangi bir
Kaygısızlar yazın absürük komedi
dizisiyle hatırlar mısınız lütfen
Bugün bir açılıp izlenebilir o kadar da
komik değil içerik abi 45 dakika 50
dakika içerikler biliyor musunuz
televizyonda yayınlanıyordu döner o
günlere haberler Bir De met tiyatro bir
dizi Beyaz Show hatırlıyorsunuz değil mi
bakın bir akşam da oluyor bunlar şimdi
haberler özet özetin özeti dizi saat bir
oluyor biliyorsunuz aynı diziyle
şimdi
radyo
radyo eski cazibesinde değil dedi ama
aslına bakarsanız dinlenmelere ve yine
Medya değerine çok enteresan bir şekilde
Spotify gibi ya da işte Fizy gibi
çeşitli müzik içeriklerine
ulaşabileceğiniz platformlara rağmen
radyonun acayip bir cazibesi var hala
arabada Dinleniyor olması vesaire
diyeceksiniz ama artık biliyorsunuz Bir
tuşla herhangi bir platforma arabaya
aktarmanız mümkün Yani biraz internet
harcama konusunda özgürseniz yani ki
onlarla çok tüketmiyorlar diye biliyorum
daha Radyo tüketiyor olmanın Radyo
içeriği tüketiyor olmanın bir yanı var
değerli bir yanı var Bu da aslında Tabii
ki orada konuşan birilerinin olması
değerli ama bir yandan da insanın
özünden gelen bir rastgelelik arzusu var
Çünkü bugün her birinize şu anda mesaj
atsam telefonunuza ve ölüm tarihlerinizi
yazsam artık Asla eskisi heyecanınıza
yaşayamazsınız
bundan 80 yıl sonra ölecek olsanız bile
150 yıl sonraki bir tarih yazsam bile
telefonlarınızı ve 2250 yazsam bile ne
zaman öleceğini bilse insan asla eski
tadıyla yaşayamaz ne Enteresan değil mi
Hem de öleceğimizden emin olduğumuz
halde o yüzden bu insanın arzuladığı bu
rastgelelik ihtiyacı Radyo tam anlamıyla
karşılıyor Çünkü siz bu müzik
platformlarından bir şey açtığınız zaman
tabii ki onların sizin heyecanınıza işte
zevkinize göre sunduğu ve bir sonra ne
çalışacağını bilmediğiniz bazı listeleri
var ama yine de Hepimiz takdir ederiz ki
yani hayatınızda birkaç saat bile Radyo
tüketmiş olsanız ne demek istediğimi
anlarsınız Aslında
Radyodaki kadar acaba Şimdi ne olacak
heyecanını o algoritmik olarak o
platformlar veremiyor Dolayısıyla
dijital her ne kadar yani Yeni
anormallikler yaratsa da bizim yine de
ne olursa olsun normal olana duyduğumuz
heyecan hala içimizde bir yerde duruyor
Çünkü bugün nasıl Shakespeare'in
macbetini 500 yılı 5 bir yıl önce
yazılmış bir oyunu bugün hala daha Bursa
şehir tiyatrosuna devlet tiyatrosunda
izlemek için sıraya giriyorsak ya da
özel ekiplerden neden yapıyoruz bunu 550
yıl önce yazılmış hepimizin Muhtemelen
çok iyi bildiği belki üçer farklı
ekipten seyrettiği bir oyunu hala niye
görmek istiyoruz Çünkü insandan
bahsediyor Çünkü orada bir tutku var bir
hırs var Kral olma arzusu var Lider olma
arzusu var bir kadın var kadının adamı
Bunlar bunların modası geçmiyor işte
modası geçmeyecek olan bazı şeyler var
bugün
ne kadar hızlı veri akışı olursa olsun
hala sevgilisini kıskanan insanlar var
Öyle değil mi Hala daha aynı şeye Üzülüp
ağlayan insanlar var Öyle değil mi
bunlar hiç değişmeyecek Ya sadece
ürünler değişiyor aslında Bunlar hiçbir
zaman değişmiyor bu çok değerli o yüzden
ben de
hedefime ve hedefime insanı aldığım için
ve ne olur yanlış anlamayın ama malzeme
olarak insanı yoğurmaya çalıştığım için
ben de içine katılıyorum tabii ki o
malzemenin Dolayısıyla aslında hiçbir
zaman modası geçmeyecek Bir iş yapıyorum
bugün Radyo içeriğini Hangi teknoloji
üzerinden Size aktardığımın hiçbir önemi
yok Çünkü ben yarın bana Deseler ki
artık wifi ile aktaracağız seni Okey
artık develerle götürdüm hiç fark etmez
yani hiç fark etmez çünkü ben içeriğimi
sunacağım ve o size gidecek yani arada
ne olduğunu ben zaten bilmiyorum bile
Çamlıca'daki antenimizi görmedim mesela
hiç bana soruyorlar Böylece videonun
frekansı kaç bilmiyorum bilmiyorum yani
bu işime hakim olmadığım anlamına gelmez
yani o Beni ilgilendirmeyen bir alan ve
bilmiyorum başka alanlarla ilgili bir
şeyler biliyorum ama yani frekansını
bilmeyip şimdi sırada konuşacağım konu
buraya yazmışım inanamıyorum kendime
hatırlatsın diye bazı keyiflerim var
bugün konuşurum diye kuantum fiziği
yazmışım manyaklığa bak ya
3 dakikam kaldı Şimdi size kuantum
fiziği anlatacağım hazırsınızı ya Hayır
rastgelelilik burada da var aslında az
önce
iki hocanın da bahsettiği Örneğin
ilk konuşmada ne gördük
görselleştirme gördük değil mi dedi ki
ben Mimar olmak istiyor ve Mimar olmanın
gerekliliklerine ait devasa bir görsel
hazırladım ve onu daha çocukken duvarıma
yapıştırdım ve hayatım Öyle gelişsin
istedim ve öyle geliştiriyor bunu bu
tanıdık geliyor mu size bir yerden
geliyor olmalı Çünkü bugün spiritüel
anlatımların aslında birçoğunda diyor ki
hayalim neyse onu görselleştir çiz
Mustafa Sandal'ın bir hikayesi var bir
ayakkabı gördüm Bunu ilk konserimde
giyeceğim dedim diyor o zaman daha ne
şarkısı var ne albümü var adını bile
bilmiyoruz adam ayakkabıyı alıyor evine
koyuyor Bunu ilk konserinde giyeceğim
diye gerçekten bir yıl sonra stadyum
konseri veriyor ve o ayakkabıyı giyiyor
bunların arasında şeyler var bağlantılar
var Bunları kurabilmek kurgulayabilmek
lazım Dolayısıyla aslında kuantumun da
anlattığı İşte bu konutun niyetten
bahseder rastgelelikten bahseder çift
yarık deneyi vardır falan bunları böyle
birer başlık halinde atıyorum neden
söylüyorum bunu biliyor musunuz Çünkü
bize şey diyorlar
Koskoca kuantum fiziğini çıkmış burada
radyoloji bilmem neresinden anlatıyor
falan filan
tamam da yani şimdi Koskoca elektrik
denen şeyi biz eve gidip aydınlanmak
için O düğmeye basıp yakıp
kullanabiliyorsak ya kuantumun da bizim
kullanabileceğimiz böyle tekil faydaları
vardır diye umuyorum Yani tabii ki
Koskoca fiziği anlamanın
anlamlandırmanın anlamlandırmanın imkanı
olmadığını biliyorum Bu bu koşullarda Ee
iyi bir okuma yapmadan ama yani insan
düzeyine indirgediğimizde maddenin
bambaşka çalıştığını görebiliyoruz artık
Deneylerle şimdi
bir suya bir su zerreciğine küfür
ettiğinizde suze'nin 15 gün içinde neye
benzediğini fotoğraflayan bir bilim
adamı aynı bilim adamı bir budistin
kutsadığı su zerre yeni
fotoğrafladığında inanılmaz kusursuz bir
kar tanesi gibi Onu gördüğünde artık bu
iki şeyin arasındaki farkı görüyoruz
Kendimiz de sudan oluşuyoruz büyük
çoğunlukla Dolayısıyla Aslında bize
küfür edildiğinde ve kutsadığımızda neye
benzediğimiz o kadar şeker ki yani
buna izin vermemek lazım diye
düşünüyorum o yüzden bugün benim emek
lazım diye düşünüyorum o yüzden bugün
benim mesleği seçerken yaşadığım o
kaygılar mesleği seçerken
yaşadığım kaygılar acaba Gelecekte bu iş
ne olur nereye gider dijital bir dünya
geliyor acaba buna bir şey olur mu
kaygıları
hiç duymadığım kaygılar oldu Hiçbir
tanıdığım
olmamasına rağmen bu işe yatırabilecek
biraz tanınır olmak için harcayabilecek
hiçbir param olmamasına rağmen bu
kaygıları hiç duymaksızın Sadece biraz
cesur olduğum için ve bana söylüyorlar
günde 3 saat çalışıyorsun sonra
yatıyorsun Oh diyorlar falan Sen
diyorlar sevdiğin işi yapıyorsun zaten
senin işin kolay diyorlar Tam da bu
noktada bir slogan gibi bir şey söylemek
istiyorum ve bitiriyorum Aslında
sevdiği işi yapıyor olmak kadar değerli
bir şey yok bu dünyada azınlığı
gerçekten Eğer İçinizde de varsa
kutsanmış olduğunu düşünebilir o
insanlar Tabii dışı sadece dış
etkenlerde kendi tercihlerini aynı
zamanda Bunlar seçimleriniz hepinizin
Bunun farkındayım Kendimden biliyorum
fakat sevdiği işi yapıyor olmanın bir
bedelinin olmadığını düşünüyor insanlar
tam tersi tam anlamıyla şöyle bir formül
koyabiliriz oraya Aslında sevdiği işi
yapan insanlar bu bedeli baştan
ödüyorlar
Hayal kırıklıklarıyla toplumsal baskıyla
aile baskısıyla
yapamazsınlarla zaten bu işi 5 kişi
yapıyor sana mı kaldılarla
ve daha bir sürü şeyle iyi bilirsiniz Bu
bedeli baştan ödeyerek savaşarak topluma
ve dünyadaki diğer herkese rağmen
savaşarak ve başararak önce
başaramayarak insanlar Bak gördün mü
yapamayacaksın demiştik buna rağmen
kalkıp devam ederek bu bedeli baştan
ödüyorlar
sevmediği işi yapanlar da bu bedeli
sonra ödüyorlar çünkü hemen mezun olup
hemen ilk fırsatta kimseyi bu arada
yadırgamıyorum yargılamıyorum biliyorum
dünyanın koşullarını o anda bulduğunuz
herhangi bir can simidine sarılmak
zorunda olduğunuzu Bunu çok iyi
biliyorum
bunu yapanlarda sevmediği işi yapmanın
bedelini 35'lerinde kırklarında
45lerinde Artık Geriye dönemeyeceklerini
hissettikleri ki Külliyen yalandır Bu da
topluma bir baskısıdır Çünkü çok bilinen
Klişe bir laf Yarın geri kalan
hayatınızın ilk günüdür der çok da
değerli bir laftır Bu bedeli
sevmediği işi seçtikten 10 sene 15 sene
20 sene sonra artık geri dönülmez
hissettiğinde yaşamaya başlar En kötüsü
de budur çünkü Eğer bir bedel ödenecekse
Bir yere koşulacaksa bir yerden
atlanacaksa bir zorluk Yaşanacaksa bunu
gençken yaşamanın biyolojik olarak
Mental olarak birçok faydası birçok
avantajı vardır herhalde aynı
fikirdeyizdir diye düşünüyorum Çok
teşekkür ediyorum inanılmaz
bir gündü
Sağ ol hoşça kalın